fear is afraid of you too interesting
break that down and like fear has so
much control but it's the same feeling
as happiness like nobody runs from
happiness fear is deathly afraid of the
day where you turn around and be like
I'm not [__] afraid of you it's funny
you say and then it loses all power fear
is fake fear hangs out with [__]
Santa Claus attention is the number one
asset vayer Nation how are you welcome
to another episode of podcast with
friends this episode is actually podcast
with former friends because
is literally [__] 30 26 minutes late
the whole show give a take I have a hard
stop at 11:30 so I want to apologize for
you two youngsters Joe has ruined your
exposure I was a fan of the show and you
know well what happened the Long Island
Expressway and don't pretend like you
don't know there was an accident I will
say there was hours 10 minutes from my
house 37 miles away I mean come on I did
what I could listen you grew up in this
area your whole life I did you should
have been here 9:00 in the morning and
you know know you're right let's go into
the show ladies first let's introduce
ourselves to the vayer nation the
concept of the show is incredibly simple
there are individuals in the world that
you know me and my team spent an ungodly
amount of time watching human beings
move in society you know Tyler Walsh
Boyd music uh Tyler Schmidt and Zach and
and overall culture i i play a lot of
role in it and we just kind of decided I
wanted to do new content this year in
2024 and the thing that most excited me
was getting people to intr
each other and get to know each other
that may not know each other admire each
other from afar but more importantly a
get my audience to meet different voices
different people to follow their
Journeys on everyone's in different
parts of their journey and execution
wise I really wanted to finally start
streaming it's something I've been
watching for a decade and I've just
never found my way in because I'm so
busy that's why vlogging worked you know
drock could follow me in my day-to-day
but this whole concept of now twitching
especially in my office we tried it last
week
where like after the show I was on mute
and just streaming in the back and
people loved it I unmuted a couple times
and I loved it and so huge shout out to
the twitch Army all of you that are
tuned in right now uh VAR Gainer Chuck
that's a great name big name for me in
high in high school my friend I'll never
forget the day my friends figured out if
they reverse my two letters that they
could really have some fun with me so I
see varry ganor chucks in the building
uh first time chat for J boy for clay
Ferno let me know how you got here I
just tweeted it I just sent it my text
or you're an OG I want all 300 of you to
right now reply OG text or Twitter let
me know how you got here but purpose of
the show is for the audience to get to
know you and for us to talk about [__]
that's popping in society or sitting on
our chests or our minds we will start
ladies first why don't you tell the
vender Nation who you are what you do
yes how far do you want me to go though
you you could it is your it is your
space okay so my name is Dina a I'm 19
years old old I'm a rock and I was born
and raised in Belgium um and I've always
been into music I'm an artist so um I
was an artist since a little kid like my
mom and my dad knew but it didn't really
take me serious so um I participated
with the voice kits in belum well I was
15 super young still in school um and
then that whole experience made me
realize that maybe being an artist is
what I want to do when I grow up so um
after that my brother used to make beats
so then we sat together and we we
decided to just make songs together have
fun and um and then I was 16 I met my
producer chuie uh and my manager Dro um
we recorded a vlog on Chuck's channel uh
a 16-year-old girl freestyling on my
beat and that had like 1 million views
in a couple of weeks um yeah a couple of
months so I was like Wow uh I really
want yeah it's I saw like what happened
on The Voice did you do well on the show
yeah it was very nice um I got to the
half uh to the semi-finals yeah so you
got a lot of exposure from that yes a
lot it was nice being on stage my first
time being on stage I was very nervous
very young but it taught me a lot so
what a stage to be on for your first
one exactly and so then after that
YouTube video popped off what happened
next uh after that I was like well I
want to sit down with my producer and
manager we're a team so I want to find
my own sound something that sounds like
Dina a and other artists so it took us
like 3 years we was locked in yeah and
we really took it serious so um and then
I decided to post a Tik Tok uh in
December on my birthday and it was a Tik
Tok of me freestyling on a random beat
cuz I don't listen to beats before I hop
on a beat oh interesting yeah wow so um
I can never do that so then I really
resonate with that if I had any musical
talent that would be more my style I'm
so so much more improv in nature like it
just comes so natural to me as a human
it's how my speaking like I literally
sometimes don't even know who I'm
speaking to right in like 4,000 people
events until I get to the location and
meet the organizer I'm like okay tell me
about the audience like I don't I'm more
comfortable he but if I throw a beat on
right now you're telling me no I have no
musical Talent if I had musical Talent
I'd be the biggest rapper in the world I
believe that believe that I'm being dead
serious I have so much real [__] to say
right oh absolutely I just have no
[__] musical
you everyone's always really nice and
car you can do it I'm like yeah Barry
Gainer Tru Barry Gainer truck in the
building and so and so where we at at
the journey now so um I was 17 at that
moment no I was turning 17 on my
birthday and I posted a Tik Tok didn't
overthink it I was like man just let it
flow um so then it took me a couple of
days um and in the meantime so I was
telling my manager bro I want to go to
La let's go to La I know I'm in school
but we can go after my exams so um so
basically I had I was in law school
beginning of the year uh and then we
booked our flights booked everything we
was ready and then after we booked our
flights and everything my Tik Tok starts
going crazy it blew up and I was like
maybe this is God's plan so after my
exams we went to LA and we were supposed
to stay there for 1 month but we um
Extended the trip so we stayed two
months and a lot of producers labels
artists they start reaching out to me so
we was really just working over there
like locked in and um I knew like maybe
when I go back to Belgium I might want
to drop out of law school cuz this music
might be for me and um when I got back
to Belgium I was I was talking to my
parents I was like yeah I think this
might be the right move for me to make
right now like I believe in it so I um I
dropped out and I did it online I
remember my manager calling me 5 minutes
later he was like Dina um somebody's
finding us out to New York next week I
was like this is God's plan yeah so it's
been an amazing journey uh after that I
just continued posting on Tik toks
everything blew up um a lot of people
reaching out and then uh and in the
beginning I told every label I want to I
want to do a support act at the end of
the year and I just got off tour with TJ
that's amazing amazing awesome so proud
of you thank you Joe that's me I'm a
freestyle rapper my name is Joe I kick
the funky flow I rock your ass from here
to Idaho hey uh I'm former Impractical
Joker comedian improv uh started with
improv when I was 19 uh ran that to the
ground got some improv experience here
in New York moved to LA to chase a dream
to be a filmmaker ended up working at
Nordstrom selling men's
pants uh mov back here in New York with
the boys perform real quick just real
quick for the kids your your big plan to
become this movie Mogul yeah go to La
yep pick it up pack it up go the the
chapter in the book on that was you
ended up just working at Nordstrom
selling pants yep selling pants all
right you good at selling pants I was
fantastic sales I was I was selling
pants all the celebrities I worked at
the Grove in LA which is all a hot spot
what makes you a pair of pants uh I I
worked at the rail which was the Men's
Wear section and this is when Von Dutch
was big you'll remember that and uh so I
was uh yeah I was rocking out there and
helping celebs and stuff and that was my
claim to fame and then I just you know I
loved sales I was always a Salesman came
back to New York and I was doing comedy
on the side till we got the me and the
guys got together to figure out what our
TV show was we F we tried a couple that
failed miserably found Jokers made that
found that concept and did that for a
decade then life gave me a couple
options of different ways to go and uh
decided to focus on family and figure it
all out and now I've been doing standup
on my own and been doing torn that for
two years Writing Movies is actually
working on something getting something
started there which is great and uh kind
been performing some big rooms which is
great I'm playing the beacon here in New
York which is the one I haven't done so
yeah the beacon in January I'm January
20th can people get tickets yeah they
can yeah how did they find that um joat
official.com no matter where you live
I'm I'm on tour but yeah the January
20th is at the Beacon which is why
official because the other one was taken
the real the
real it kind of goes the real that's
like the rule right like it's your name
if you can get it if you can't get your
name you get the real and if you can't
get that you go with the official
official yeah yeah I even had to do
underscore G for my all my handles I'm
an underscore guy say you're an
underscore guy yeah I really feel like
if you're an underscore person like
shit's just not you know you could
probably find it's just a common name I
mean you got don't have a common name Jo
in New York I [__] it up I like added
two silent e to it I'm supposed to be
this branding expert and like completely
[__] it up anyway how how are you
enjoying stand up right now I love it I
love it yeah is that your like favorite
place to be to entertain is to make
people laugh and now you can get in
front of people and do it that way but I
enjoy writing I enjoy all of it I've
always enjoyed all of it you know I've
been doing a bunch of different Avenues
now that the time is like you know I've
had the time now wrote a kids book which
is coming out next year which Jo already
up but there's 800 people now on Twitch
which is a real number there you go and
I feel like you should say something to
them all right everyone watching on
Twitch we just wanted to get you all
together and say you know be kind to
each other oh hey
amen be kind to each
other that's it man you got to be kind
because you know life sucks suck harder
friends get out there and do what you
got to do and just keep smiling and
spread some joy I love that my brother
so uh my name is Nick C I go I'm on
Instagram Tik Tok YouTube Nick the
official the official
Nick actually the real nick uh with an
underscore at the end but yeah I started
no really what is your head nikk cast
nikki. c so I
started no but wait so funny story so
that's the same handle that I had in
high school so like what I was my whole
thing was like I was a big Sports guy I
played baseball my whole life and I
didn't really think that this was ever
in the cards and then one day uh I was
training clients in a gym I thought I
was going to open up a gym and do this
whole thing I was training clients out
of my garage I always had like the
entrepreneurial Spirit um anytime I
wanted to like make make some money my
dad would tell me to go wash the cars or
like I'd sell stuff on eBay so um grew
up like that but uh my bud I was always
the like the class clown so like every
sports team I was on I was always like
bound to make you laugh and it just
always felt so good but it came natural
so I was never like yeah the way you
talk it's Talent you know what's funny
so I was so I was no but okay no all
right I believe that no yeah for real
cuz I would I used to play on this
travel baseball team and I was the only
kid from New York and every time I open
my mouth start laugh like I didn't
[__] say anything yeah yeah like but
they were all from the side I'd say like
all right here we go kid they go all
here we we go so it was the whole thing
I never like I said it just kind of
became natural so uh posted on Tik Tok
the first video blew up and uh the first
one the first one got 2 million yeah 2
million views your first TI Tok my first
Tik Tok got 2 million views so I was
working in a gy this was 2020 yeah um I
was trying to tell it was right before
the pandemic I was trying boy you know
this I was you definitely know this I
was trying to tell everybody but see
like I got because of you I didn't have
like it wasn't part like my buddies were
just like cuz I would send the [__] to
my buddies and they were like post it
and I'm like I'm you know I'm just going
to open up the gym by the way on that
cuz I just want to give value to the
audience yeah by the way 807 all of you
share the [__] out of this link right
now in and this is where I'm going don't
share it on social share this link right
now to that thread we all have that
thread we all have that WhatsApp or
iMessage group text where like to your
point everyone's their best version in
their best friends text grip 100% I've
got a Jets one and a Nicks one and a
college one and like like a sports card
one and like like we all have them and I
feel like for a lot the reason I'm
jumping in right now I apologize jumping
in is I believe that there's 25 people
listening right now for sure that are in
a thread where their buddies are saying
you should do fantasy football fulltime
you're the smartest and best one of our
crew but they're like nah I'm not
Matthew Barry or you're funny which is
obviously very common cuz humor is a
foundation of group chats but like humor
or knowledge yep I'm telling you for the
25 out of the million that listen this
podcast over the next 3 years in the
long tale of
consumption please use this as a sign
God's plan back to your point as like
you know what [__] it my friends have
been telling me for two years I've
secretly been thinking about it for two
months use this m this dude's first Tik
Tok the first one wow the first [__]
one and and to be honest with you to
that point too like if I if I didn't put
myself link to a bunch of your posted I
was it was 8 minutes I'll never forget
it was a Wednesday night 7:52 p.m. I'm
working in the gym my college right so I
got six clients that I'm training I
worked in The Athlete gym down
downstairs at the school that I was at I
was like you know what like no one's
coming in [__] it I'm just going to make
a video so I made it's quick 15-second
video post it didn't think anything of
it the next morning I woke up and it was
just going ballistic but then I deleted
you didn't have you didn't have alerts
on so you didn't know nothing I Gary I
woke up in the morning what and I'm
going to do my routine in the morning
and my phone is what is your routine in
the morning I mean personal okay so I
wake up the first thing I do I take my
pills I take a heart medic uh not a
heart I I take a multivitamin I take a a
probiotic you confused a hard medication
and a multivitamin yeah no I did I did
there's no there's no going back but but
but uh well cuz my buddy takes a heart
medication and we were on the topic but
uh yeah anyway bottom bottom line I had
not put myself out there I wouldn't have
realized that that I did have a gift
that I did have talent and that I
actually love the sport of business so
the the onset of like just put yourself
out there I think like I was always kind
of good with with me no matter what so
like if I if it just didn't work out I'm
like I don't care you had self-esteem
correct and so it [__] matters for
sure H 20 years into this journey 15 and
especially 5 to seven on the [__] I'm
talking about yeah this is a binary i i
i basic I I feel I can already feel at
48 that my 65-year-old content is going
to be super weird cuz all I'm going to
want to say is it is self-esteem versus
insecurity I don't want to talk to you
[__] people about anything else like
if you if you are insecure someone made
you insecure go to get therapy
meditation change your routine cut your
friends out that make you feel that way
like enough [__] enough stop like all
you [__] people out there that are
just willing to lean into cynicism and
negativity and darkness I promise you
it's just a pure reflection of what's in
your heart like this is a binary game
you were good and this is what why I'm
jumping in again everyone who feels that
they're good that's listening should
only live putting themselves out there
24/7 cuz nothing bad can happen cuz
you're good 100% there's no there's no
like fear of what are people going to
say if it doesn't do well and like my
friends my friends would say like I
remember I went to lunch with this with
one of I'm not really friends with him
anymore but he he was like like you just
don't ever feel like weird like putting
stuff out on I'm like no man that's him
feeling we like he couldn't do that he
would worry about what the girl that he
thinks is cute things he would worry
about what his mom thinks he would worry
about what you would think about him for
sure like everything good in my life is
based on the fact that I deeply care
about people but not their subjective
opinions about me yes I deeply care
about people even strangers or
acquaintances that are becoming
strangers become acquaintances
acquaintances become friends be friends
that's what this is and and most of all
back to Mike boydd and Dustin's on his
journey and you'll get there over time
and then friends become [__] family
amen mhm it's nobody's business it's not
your business what other people think of
you and that's something that's always
stuck in my head it's not your business
I just really want to have this combo
while we're on it like please explain to
me what somebody saying your [__]
actually means it means actually nothing
right like actually yeah no it literally
means absolutely nothing like absolutely
because well I will say this though
don't you don't you think like uh I mean
we all have Confidant right so if you
are in the because I feel like sometimes
there is that fine line not caring what
people think versus caring what people
think who care about you and I think you
have to look about where a place it
comes from because I've been a different
fine line of not being delusional I'm
not sitting here saying I hate when
people say like I'm trying to be a
little bit better about like other
people's opinions don't matter actually
they do matter like I use people's
feedback confs or strangers by the way
for me Neil cut comp and salsa chick
Linda like their opinion does matter to
me like do they think I'm too abrasive
do they think I'm awesome do they think
like it it I I use it as feedback but I
can't internalize it for sure as the
thing that gives me validation for my
life by the way the key for me is not
accepting the accolades the reason I
think I do well with negativity is cuz I
don't believe when people call me great
yeah I'm just in the middle I think one
of the thing cuz in the world of what we
do like everybody's a Critic and and and
what I've come to realize and like even
even though like if you're secure in
yourself like I like I would say like if
everyone at this table is pretty secure
in themselves but there are times where
you you do question like on the on the
journey up like I'm sure when you were
coming up and when you were doing your
thing like I I've developed this analogy
called the dinner table MH and so I get
six chairs at my dinner table I pick six
people when people come to me and they
either say like you should do this you
should do that I don't like this I don't
like that I think to myself are you
sitting at my dinner table if you're not
I'll take what you say but again I'm not
going to internalize it so for me that's
been super valuable in the whole cuz
when you're when you're out there every
day like people are getting perceptions
of you and like who you are Y and if you
try and live up to that expectation of
what you think it is you're you're not
being you I you know I also think it
starts at home of how for me one of the
reasons I also don't struggle that much
with with judgment is I don't judge I've
been paying attention to a lot of people
that are struggling with it I'm like oh
right yeah you're in the business you
spend all day going through the feed and
judging people too you're judging people
which is why you're vulnerable to
judgment I don't know these people right
I don't even know Dustin and Boyd like
that these are guys I really know but I
don't really know I know some nuances
but I haven't been in their home 30 50
100 times it's not like I've had like
I'm not having a monthly dinner for 2
hours with them like so like if I don't
know [__] people that are in my inner
circle I definitely don't know anybody
like I don't think anybody really knows
anybody besides themselves even your
parents and your siblings I think what
I'm about to say we hit for all of us
you know that not a person on Earth
knows absolutely everything yeah every
one of us right now has some [__] that
we know about ourselves that we know not
one person on there is not one person on
Earth that fully knows you besides
yourself yeah that's true and so people
are just sitting out here judging people
24/7 because it's become a [__]
National Pastime which is why they're
[__] susceptible to judgment I'm on
some here's my judgment back to the joke
you made and and I know that we connect
on this because I I see you see me and
I'm very grateful for it here's my
judgment I just hope you're good mhm
right like I struggle seeing anyone in
my feed you should see me at the airport
like I just want to talk to everyone I
love people I hope you're good life is
amazing and at times hard I cheer for
people it's the format of this show what
do I want out of the show that these 800
people and these 80,000 people that
listen this week start liking you more
start listening to music watch your
videos go to your show like if you're
not leaving positive deposits what the
[__] are you doing right yeah do you
think though that's because of the the
things that you pull value to like as a
human being like the things that you
find valuable maybe you mean like the
New York Jets yeah Jets not buying them
I mean like watching
them like the New York well I mean
you're fing I find Value in one
place kindness right I find Value in
like the warmth of knowing that if I'm
struggling for a period of time that if
I can call Brandon wariki or my mom I'll
be good in a second cuz those are go-to
people for me where I know if I call
it's going to be a smile and I'm that
for the world yeah my mother used to say
all the time watch how people treat old
people and animals and that's how you
know how their heart is whole thing she
was
like no she's passed yeah um yeah I feel
the same way well yeah you feel more
than I do I uh I you know I actually
have a weird relationship with animals I
I actually resent that's a clip I have a
I have a real statement here I it's a
very my team always tells me not to
bring this up they're always scared that
it's going to be clipped out of context
uh I resent the way humans blindly treat
animals and not Each Other M it pisses
me off I don't know what else to say I
wish the world treated each other the
way
that [__] just happened [__] is that
this Google [__] screen I think you
had double like fingers or something
what the [__] is the thing on I thought
it was
broken
black let me finish this thought it's
incredibly important we are you see a
dog you're just like oh you pure love
yeah we see humans and most people have
fear when they see a stranger mhh I feel
like I'm very scared of of animals me
too like but wow [__] those
animals but I think it's important to to
really like have that bond with a with
animals too like the same way you have a
bond with people like you should treat
everybody the same way but people people
are comfortable with animals cuz they
can't talk back exactly other they don't
feel like they're judging them exactly
that's right humans are petrified of
other humans they deep like let's play
it let's go around the horn what's your
general Vibe when you meet strangers or
new people like how do you how does it
usually play out cautious you know trust
is earned give like how do you kind of
roll when you meet people I'm very real
talk like real vulnerable real talk like
from all three of you I [__] mean it
because I want value out of this show
like for y'all but also for the audience
what is your default when you meet
people honestly I feel like I don't
trust very easily I always I when I meet
people I always have good energy like I
smile and I make sure that they like my
first impression is always very
important but I can't trust you right
away like I got to know you I got to
talk to you communicate with you to know
what type of person you are and uh from
there on like we got to build up our
relationship but um I think it's very
important to also not think negative uh
negatively about other people right away
and don't judge right so it's not that
you feel negative but it's a neutral
with a caution because you want to make
cuz trust is important exactly trust is
important yeah I think it depends on my
mind space where mood you're in reflects
directly makes sense by the way that's
every1 directly like if I and also like
if I'm with my family like I'm super
protective like my kids because
everybody always like I strangers taking
pictures of my kids is weird like I
always everybody always wants a pictures
you know it is and I always get super
like I go into dad mode and sometimes I
just have to explain I'm being a father
right now not a uh you know not I'm with
my kid right now that kind of thing so
they do that most do some don't but most
do and then again that's not my problem
that's theirs like that's what I'm doing
I have to worry about my kid my daughter
my son and you know this like I'm going
through it now like what you never think
about is like most I've come to learn
most kids that have someone who's a
parent of notoriety hate it yeah
hate yeah they don't think it's cool
they think it blows yeah yeah they don't
want people like them because of you
right they don't want they try to they
don't want people taking the time away
from them and you in the limited time
you have yep for the but for the most
part I'm there to make like I truly
believe I live to make people laugh I'm
here to make people smile so for the
most part I'm there unless I'm running
for a plane and I'm late but overall I
think that and I think people get that
from me too but I'm just in a weird
place cuz people I've been on TV 10
years they seen they've seen me I wasn't
playing char so they feel like they know
me it's I come in a different way but
that I think really depends on where I'm
at yeah I think I think I try to control
the controllable so like for me I'm not
I'm not concerned about the person's
reaction I just know that I can control
my own energy and I'm huge on energy so
like I'll put as much good as I can out
there even on days and I used to say all
the time like during the pandemic like
discipline is is a thing that you do
with like if you're trying to accomplish
something but I also think discipline is
a thing that you you do when you treat
people so like even if I'm not feeling
100% I try and give even if I got to
like force it out of give it out because
I do feel like the universe is going to
reciprocate that energy back like my
godmother always used to say be the
energy that you wish to attract so I
just try and be consistent with that and
if somebody's not feeling it bro I
[__] I [__] love you for this like
on real talk and honestly you know
what's so funny I used to be on the
track of like [__] them but I didn't
mean it right you know where where I'm
at it's not [__] him it's actually I'm
in full I feel bad my compassion The
Compassion of catfish is here actually
let's open these packs we're doing the
befriends part
now ni see oh I'm excit right now hold
on this dude they just traed packs I
want to
see I caught him off guard I like that
all right all right uh what I want you
to do is go through these V friends look
at all your cards and decide which
character you most associate with you
getting glasses you ready for this here
we go there is by the way I'm going
through it too brother I'm like getting
close have to do oh I got my f i got
literally I got my favorite underrated
character here's some Alpha for be
friends I'm getting serious about
developing this character I just got I
got a good one polish pole polish oh you
pulled a good one she pulled a shiny oh
a rare one this one no no but look at
the names shiny one pick one character
that most represents you but you know
what's funny back to compassionate
catfish being here I was never [__] them
I was always like first and youth I was
like they don't matter like no peer
pressure didn't feel it now in my older
age when someone's coming with the wrong
energy to me especially I'm like you I
come out the gate like [__] Fire H of
POS and love I'm always trying to make
people feel comfortable cuz I'm so
comfortable and I know most people
aren't comfortable so I'm trying to make
the whole scene comfortable if someone's
really not about that towards me I go
into like my God I just came in here and
love bombed the [__] out of this room
when humble especially now that I have
like notoriety now my like I did this
when I was 19 and no one on earth knew
who the [__] I was and it would work as
a good thing for people now you carry
some reputation so it's even double
Works everyone's like oh okay cool so
now if I see Darkness to that I'm like
that person is in a deep bad place and
like I need to like double down and try
to get them out I I go like why like why
like what has gotten you to this point I
usually think it's like real [__] up
[__] like
by the way just like talking about real
life back to gratitude everybody big sh
out to everybody here Wester Jack what's
good good since 82 first time chat let's
clap it up for good right all right my
in my intuition is they were born in '
82 so I found that awesome um but
podcast twitch who's watching live if
you're listening to the podcast go to go
to Gary
ve.com twitch subscribe up make sure you
catch us live in the
future my big thing now though is like
look like
for example real talk I had a 6:00 to 7:
p.m. meeting today with a journalist
literally yeah because Joe was I don't
know if you guys know this twitch I
don't know if you know this podcast if
you're listening Joe was so
inappropriately late right and made this
episode much shorter if you're watching
right now you're like wait a minute most
are 60 Minutes why is this only 35
that's Joe it's all Joe's fault but
because of Joe being so wildly late we
had a great conversation we did but but
I I I got to see this text from my
admins this this meeting is cancelled
tonight because she's on a plane right
this second to Chicago cuz her mom had a
heart attack MH like I don't think
people understand how life actually
works we're worried about all this dumb
[__] and real life [__] real life [__]
is happening since we've done this
podcast ungodly amounts of tragic things
have happened in the world and I don't
see that as dark I see that as my God
I'm so grateful that that hasn't
happened in my inner circle yet yeah yet
mhm nobody lives to a 100 without
heartbreak you know I mean nobody comes
out on but that's the thing too though
like if you're in the landscape that
we're on you're putting out so people
are just seeing the product but like
dayto day I mean it's I mean I don't
know how it is for everyone but I'm by
myself creating ideas wearing all these
different hats I mean I got a team now
that that help me I'm so grateful for
but like we're human beings at the end
of the day too so there flag them down
just said Joe for president 2024
interrup your brother Joe are you
willing to announce your presidential
run right here on podcast with friends
sure how many votes do you think you're
going to get seven
teen present company not included I got
two in this room I don't know I'm so
working on V for you you out your
[__] you show up late to the campign
let's go which which character out of
the V friends you pulled most spoke to
you I got oh I love this I got tough to
beat a worm from the dirt o oh look
there is a worm in V friends whose name
is tough to beat a worm from the dirt
why did that connect with you I wanted
to ask you like can you explain I can
but why did it associate on your first
reaction what hit you you like worms or
I
do I with worms like and flowers yeah oh
the flowers um I like wor yeah I'll
explain this really simple this is one
of truly one of there's 283 characters
this is oh I'm sorry this is literally
literally genuinely one of my favorite
character characters see if I get the
light here um there you go boom so let
me tell you why I love this character M
I feel like this is me and I feel like
it's all the people I [__] with mhm I
believe that if you're lucky enough to
be born into humble
environments and you have love around
you you become undefeated MH that you
know that I think there's incredible
vulnerability with privilege at Youth
and it leads to a lot of the things I
think about which is insecurity and
confidence when you come from the dirt
yeah you don't you don't you know what
life feels like when you don't have
stuff and fame and money and fancy
things and even the toughest
upbringings have many days of happiness
in that dirt and I think it gives you a
better perspective of life like I just
think that that worm it's kind of like
and I mean I'm going to go actually even
deeper this is an alpha story growing up
I used to play with worms a lot we were
80s kids we like this is just what we
did in New Jersey and then I just like
the dirt and then I thought about dirt
and worm and I think a lot of kids
there's 10 15 19 16 7 9 10 13 and even
20 30 40 year olds right now who don't
give themselves enough credit for their
resilience oh sure and resilience is
required yeah 100% anything and anything
resilience is required so the [__]
worm is one of my favorite characters
I'm a big fan I'm glad you picked that
Joey I went with a polished poodle
please tell
me when I look at you probably the last
thing I think about is [__] but the
first thing you think about is
poodle I'm a I'm a dog guy I mean I have
a I have a you know a nonprofit round
dogs old dogs so Gatt pups and Friends
shout out to the shout out that hold on
let's do that again not as fast shout
out to URL so people can go and maybe G
Gat pups and friends is our nonprofit we
launched last year yeah that's aom
that's not an official that's gups and
friends.com or on Instagram m g pups and
friends it's on nonprofit We started
last year mostly senior and unwanted
dogs had our 57th uh adoption last week
cinnamon roll found a home so it was
great but uh I was I'm a dog guy I love
dogs and I feel like I'm a little
polished right now because I did some
real self-work over the past couple
years I'm proud of so I think I feel
like I'm a little in this stage of me
right now so that's to me so awesome
Nikki I got the uh principal praying
mantis I pick that because I wouldn't be
where I am today without principal
because I think you talk about growing
up in in humble beginnings growing up
like we were very fortunate like I had a
roof over my head I had a loving family
but I also had a father that worked
every day yeah and when he worked every
day like he was a leader and like leader
they when when there's a natural-born
leader it's action it's not telling you
like he just [__] got up and [__]
went to work it's not preaching it's
putting in 100% and whenever I wanted to
do something whenever I wanted to
accomplish something he instilled in me
that you have to work for what you get
and so being that I didn't really
necessarily come out of the mud but when
I was 9 years old painting my whole
[__] fence back to front well you
know what's funny let's talk about that
there's a lot of kids that grow up in
middle class upper middle class and even
occasionally wealthy families that the
parents are just like [__] this [__] and
like you know yes we're not poor but
like we're not giving you money after 10
and so like you want money 10 I get it
if I wanted Madden it was go watch each
Windows $5 at a car the whole thing so I
think your dad taught you ining those
principles in me and seeing principles
be expressed has led me to that's a
rookie card too there's a series one as
you can see these white backs right here
where those are my original drawings
yeah those are my original drawings um
but this is series that's your original
I'm sorry that's your original Dr I drew
that I drew you weren you weren't
kidding with the no artist no [__] you
bro what me look at this that's [__]
youw that's I don't even know what that
is I get a side by side here wait wait a
minute wait a minute I'm about to really
[__] with you though [__] you I drew
this and this is fresh wow all right
respect respect okay hold on hold on
then you all start through this exactly
what are you talking about that's a
jolly [__] Jack what is that like
honestly what is give me that me that's
your worst nightmare [__] that dude's
going to come to your house and your
[__] thr think I'm going to be scared
of that is what I'm
saying yeah maybe maybe you took a
couple our classes in between those two
car all right let me give you mine okay
the tenacious termite favorite word is
that your favorite word tenacious my
faite am I saying obsessed with tenacity
like again back to like what I think
everyone's trying to do here and by the
way you said something earlier about
like the concept of it being an
emotional thing not a physical thing I
don't recall the what the reference was
but that's how I think about tenacity
you know like I I think the
emotional success that I think everybody
who's watching right now or listening I
think this is probably the most
interesting thing that I'm personally
working on I've been in the lab and that
means in my head mhm shower flights
driving it's the best it's the lab it's
the actual [__] lab right best
[__] I've been in the lab and all I'm
thinking about is if I can Market to the
world the redefining of
success to be peace of mind mhm and
smiling mhm yeah instead of [__]
stuff MH I could leave the biggest
impact of all time and I don't know why
one wouldn't try totally and so I I just
I think tenacity is an incredible trait
but it's a but it's the tenacity not to
go on tour every day or make music every
day or be an entrepreneur build content
it's the tenacity to fight for
calm yeah that's what we're trying to
100 no 100% And I think too like when
you get to the place where because
social media is great but it's also a
dangerous place because there's so many
people telling you what they think you
should do even if even if you're so deep
rooted in who you are and a lot of
people are trying to Define what success
is and what they think your success
should be and like if you kind of tune
into that it could be a dangerous place
by way by the way Nikki on that I know
people have this take on social I will
say this
pre-social the my issue was you only had
a couple of voices right your parent to
find success you were stuck in that two
person game whereas now all these other
voices to your point there's unlimited
garbage yes but if you try to find the
gold there's more gold out there than
ever was the way we grew up we didn't
have these voices there was none of us
you also get you get the world instead
of your neighborhood right think about
the circle of people that are
influencing you talk to me about some
I'm going to end with dreams tell me a
dream you have I we've gone deep you
could make it far more light I'd rather
it actually be a little more selfish
than the selfless talk we just did like
a fun thing like winning an Academy
Award or like you know you're so young
in the journey compared to us old guys
We're Young by the way anybody under 90s
young 92 year olds I apologize um where
you at what's a dream of yours at this
point I have a lot of dreams cuz break
them down I have the vision girl but uh
I want to I want to get n nominated for
for the Grammy Awards next year I see
myself winning a Grammy soon I believe
in my dreams all that that's why
everything I speak into existence why do
why do you why do you value
soon soon because I I believe like I can
make it work soon do you do you feel
like wanting it soon
potentially has any impact on your
output I I I'll I'll tell you where I'm
going I'm I'm worried about soon okay
because for me it's like if you WI a
Grammy in seven years you're a child mhm
yeah and and that's fresh and amazing
and I think it takes a little pressure
off your chest because when you put soon
or fast on it mhm it sometimes changes
the things people do because they think
they need to achieve it in a window to
put an ideology out of pedestal thoughts
mhm no yeah I feel like soon for me
means whenever God is handing it to me
when like God's plan like it'll come
whenever it'll come so fight for it as
fast as possible cuz that's the tenacity
but you're chill if you get it in 19
years not in 19 weeks yeah put work yeah
exactly I just want to make it work I
just want to like I honestly like I
always take my time with everything I
just dropped an EP I took my time with
that too it came together very
organically I wasn't forcing it I was
like I think it was God telling me like
right now Dena is your time to put it
out there so um other than the Grammy I
want to work you you like
intuition yeah you go with it or do you
overthink it like when what you feel in
your stomach does your brain have SE
is it a partner to your stomach or does
it actually overrule your stomach it
used to cuz I used to overthink a lot
but right now I really just go with my
intuition like I trust my gut feeling so
whatever my gut feeling yeah I feel like
God's plan is a cousin to the intuitive
stomach tag team yeah I I think it's the
biggest Miss in society right now I
think we've over rationalized in the
last 100 years and that if you go back a
100 years there was unlimited people
walking around of like you know like
evil eye and stomach and and I think I
think intuition is underrated yep mhm it
really is yeah I I agree with that I
think you got to go with I mean
everybody you're your own Compass you
know cuz you know that feeling you know
the feeling when it's right you're
accountable for your own right so it all
falls on you% I think that's part of it
you know
exactly um keep talking amongst yourself
I'm trying to buy more time in the
podcast okay keep building on that uh
thoughts on that I would well I would
the thing about it's funny because like
I think it's also a young thing too
because like when I was 19 years old you
know and I look where I am now at 47 so
different right like it took me I'm an
18-year overnight success it took me as
almost a year a year older than you
right to make it like I was do an improv
in U little little buildings you know so
you got you got to really take your time
with that too which is good but I love
that if as long as you're putting the
work in I think that's what's important
but I love how you said 18e overnight
success like it looks overnight where
these guys come from and you don't
realize all the work you're putting in
behind the scenes and nobody sees it
Nobody Does It What's Done in the Dark
one day comes to the light and when you
when when it happens it's like everybody
oh overnight no [__] I've been
like the whole the whole way here I've
been I've been working but let's get a
question or two from twitch twitch what
do you got um I agree Dena is a
superstar this is going to be fun to
look this is going to be a lot of fun to
watch in like N9 years like and be like
she was [__] in our office yeah right
like you oh I remember Joe we miss
him the rest in peace that ain't even
right I hate that [__] I hate that I
hate that [__] don't even [__] put
it out I don't like that [__] don't even
[__] put that [__] my grandmother
does that all the time I'm like no stop
Grand Grandma are supposed to do that
that's leverage be like if you don't
listen
be no one day I'm going no be here
you're going to do while I'm here you're
going to miss me when I'm gone the
balls uh forever 1620 let's go with you
Nikki cuz you're so early in your career
what's your biggest takeway so far from
your career H will Joe got be at Von
next year uh August 8th to the 11th in
La want to come up and like make some
people laugh do I'm there all right
we're going to work on I'm actually yeah
I'm not toring then all right we're
going to figure that out at this point
you're two seconds in but at this point
your single biggest takeaway from this
career you have as a emerging public
figure that you wouldn't have thought
the day before you posted that first Tik
Tok you didn't see coming you're like oh
[__] this uh fear is afraid of you too
interesting break that down and and if
you like fear is like like has so much
control but it's the same feeling as
happiness so if you run at like nobody
runs from happiness fear is deathly
afraid of the day where you turn around
and be like I'm not [__] afraid of
you it's funny you say and then it loses
all power and you could be afraid and do
all these like I given I've done a ton
of [__] scared out of my mind but I'm
still me because I'm not going to let
fear beat me and I think you know like
for the past 3 years I've been afraid in
multiple occasions but my godmother told
me you know you have to embrace every
emotion but you can't be every emotion
so when when I do feel fear I'm just
like all right well I'm afraid but I'm
still going to do what the f I'm meant
to do it's it's so funny it's literally
incredibly similar to one of my favorite
quotes for myself that I say
occasionally but I say to myself all the
time which is fierce f fake it's yeah
it's fake as [__]
fear hangs out with [__] Santa
Claus wait a minute what you what the
wait what are you saying I'm saying oh
my God this reminds me of something that
I got to tell you do you know what do
you know when I stop telling jokes
fourth grade do you know why why Denise
Lori if you're out there big shout out
Denise Lori was my sister's best friend
okay in first in kind she was in
kindergarten I was in fourth my sister
was in first grade we come home from
school
all this is 80s life all outside
chilling even it was the best you were
just outside constantly living parents
knew there's [__] parents right now
that have [__] trackers on their kids
in college I was six my mom had no
[__] clue where the [__] I was I was
in the neighborhood
somewhere different world though Gary
you know World Bingo same all right I
[__] tricked you n it's [__] safer
now with all these phones and everything
kidnappers are like [__] this [__] with
Amber somebody to see you it's safer
it's so [__] sa to see you get stuck
in 10 times safer it's just that the
news became a business and selling fear
which is fake [__] works anyway Joe
last time I told the joke so I hear this
joke it [__] rips all day in fourth
grade I'm killing people they're like
you're the [__] you're Richard Pryor
I'm like I'm Richard PR [__] killing
it I come home and I tell this joke to
my crew Robbie turnick Marissa bird and
Greco Denise Lor big shout out giving
all the shout Eric Godfrey alen Godfrey
I'm like gang let me [__] I'm on my
way I'm going to be a practical joker in
the future I'm that guy like here's the
joke all right if the Tooth Fairy the
Easter Bunny and Santa Claus were in a
room and I threw a quarter in the middle
of the room who would get
it no one cuz there's no such thing as
the Tooth Fairy Santa Claus and the
Easter Bunny so I tell this joke
everyone's dying laughing except Denise
Lori starts cry crying cuz you dropped
the truth bomb on that ass because she
still believe it gets worse it gets
worse father came to see you worse worse
where is he dingdong oh [__] get to the
get to the uh door Denise's mom who is
literally may she rest in peace one of
the greatest women I ever met in my life
you want to talk about sweetness
sweetness again back to 80s all the
moms by the way you you want to talk
about how different [__] was in 1985 if
you got fresh or did some wrong [__] in
the neighborhood and you were on your
friend's lawn their mom could smack you
yeah for sure I was smacked by women
that were not my mom and I said thank
you very much I'm sorry I'm sorry
apologize imagine that [__] Happening
Now n come on now no I can't but I
ruined her [__] life she came over
and nothing hurts more than and I was a
I was a good leader in the neighborhood
she just looked me dead in the face and
she said I'm disappointed in you
honestly I can't even tell you what's
going on in my body telling this I've
never told this story it was [__]
devastating anyway I don't know if you
know this but Santa's fake okay there's
just all people crying in the and and
fear hangs out with Santa fear is fake
fear is some [__] you made up and we
need to get the [__] [__] out of the
system cuz right now unfortunately if
you want to know what's going on in the
world
it's that fear is on fire it has
momentum it is on fire politicians have
weaponized it parents have weaponized it
school systems have weaponized it humans
have weaponized it young Generations
have weaponized it on old gener it is
the weapon of choice and I [__] hate
it more than anything on Earth I [__]
hate fear as much as I hate bill
bich that's a lot [__] yeah drop that
mic I think we were talking about dreams
yeah I want to I want to own a
pony uh HB Cu uh said grad said Gary
tell me more about becoming a full-time
streamer I said this the other day I'm
very real on this I think what I'm doing
right now everyone for me I don't have
time if I was 22 I would get in front of
a camera and stream all day it is very
clear to me that live is the opportunity
right now for all three of you I
couldn't push you more enough to do T
Tok live all day long all day long
brushing your teeth driving you know
make pretend you're late on the train to
a meeting like whatever you like to I
drove by the way I drove you drove your
own car my good for you I do that all
the time I I just really really really
think that live and so anyway what did I
what did I mean I mean that uh that I
really genuinely believe that streaming
is a huge platform people are interested
in people yeah you don't have to put on
a show you don't have to I don't have to
give a keynote I'm about to stop this
and go on mute and you got to are going
to want people are going to watch in the
background me going on with my day and
that's interesting because it's an
Insight because I can tell you this
16-year-old me would have looked up to
Gary ve and would have thought it was
[__] cool to see how he does his day
I'm like okay like I didn't know that
that to me like I'm huge on watching
people being observant and watching how
people move so if I if I take a yeah I
got binoculars I got the whole thing but
like i' i' pushes i' nck lives in the
bush no I do no no no like I'm watching
everything and so like when I see that
like when I watch people work I take
what I can and I and I almost like and
and that's a thing and that's why like
I'm so blessed to be living in this area
is like there's so much free [__]
game out there you just got to pay
attention and you just got to look for
it you just got to have the hunger to do
I need to get rid of my fear of the
camera my friends if someone says you're
not
attractive they're a piece of [__] yeah
for sure they're piece of [__] I don't
know what to say like can we just can we
you like this one like I don't know what
if someone comes on your [__]
platform and comes to you they come to
your home right your page is your home
yep and they don't take off the shoes
and they look you in the face and say
you're ugly they are a piece right of
[__] [__] for sure that's how we're
ending the show thank you boys girls
thank you thank
[Music]
you
oh